If someone speaks a little bit of German
and gets complimented or Japanese,
they're very proud of themselves that
they were able to say anything at all
in those languages that they've learned.
Whereas with English,
that's not good enough.
With English, there's a feeling that I
have to be almost like a native speaker.
Hi, Jennifer.
Hi, Steve.
Thanks so much for having me.
Thank you.
No, I'm looking forward to talking to you.
You do very important work.
You teach English and in particular
with English, you often hear about
people who are afraid to speak or
think they don't speak very well.
And yet these are people who
have spent years and years.
And so I ask myself, there's more
resources available for learning
English than any other language.
So why is it that these people
still feel not satisfied with their
level in English, in your opinion?
That's a great question.
And a lot of it, I think, comes
down to their expectation.
They have this expectation that
they're going to be able to communicate
the same way as a native speaker.
My students always compare...
The way they speak in English to the
way I speak in English they are upset
because our their accent isn't the exact
same as mine or their vocabulary isn't
Advanced as mine and obviously it's
just not a fair comparison And also I
find that the students learning English
a lot of them that I have they've been
learning English their entire lives but
throughout their lives learning English,
they've been in these environments
where they're constantly assessed.
They're constantly assessed
with language exams.
They're constantly told they're making
mistakes and they've developed this, this
fear of using their English or they expect
perfection because of how often they're
assessed and then they don't realize
when they get into the professional
world, the working world, or even social
environment that the language is not so
rigid and there's a lot more flexibility
with the language in the real world.
I think you raised a few
very good points there.
First of all, it seems that
people have higher expectations of
themselves when it comes to English
than they do for other languages.
So if someone speaks a little bit of
German and gets complimented or Japanese,
uh, they're very proud of themselves that
they were able to say anything at all
in those languages that they've learned.
Whereas with English,
that's not good enough.
With English, there's a
feeling that I have to be.
Almost like a native speaker and of
course, that's simply not possible.
That's so true and also I find that my
students, they also compare how they
speak in English to how they speak in
their own native language, which also is
not a fair comparison obviously and this
creates a lot of anxiety in them because
they think about how they would answer a
question in their native language and then
when they go to answer that question in
English, They struggle a little bit more.
The words don't flow as easily.
And they see this as a huge problem and
they see this as, Well, I'm not fluent.
I'll never progress.
My English is terrible.
But, of course, they can't
compare it to a native speaker.
And they can't compare it to how
they speak in their own language.
Oh, absolutely.
I mean, when you consider how much we
have read and how much we have listened
to our native language, so the brain has
so much experience with the language.
So that's, again, why I emphasize input.
You can't get to that level of
input experience with the language,
but the more you invest in
getting exposure to the language.
The, the more weapons you will have when
you go to speak, have you had success
stories where people have come to you and,
and obviously were struggling and were you
able to find ways to help them improve?
Yes, thankfully I have had
success with many students.
So first I had to think about all
the mistakes that students were
making and what was really preventing
them from reaching their goal.
Again, their goal is just
communicating in English.
I realized that there were really
two things we needed to do.
We had to fix their mindset
because they had to get over that.
fear of making mistakes, that fear of
being judged, how critical they are
of themselves when they're speaking.
So addressing those and just helping them
relax and have fun speaking and just see
it in a different way really helped them
to progress with their speaking skills.
And for the more technical language
skills, vocabulary, grammar
expressions, it was by helping them.
Get content, get input
that they really enjoyed.
So for my students, I help them learn
with TV shows, YouTube videos, movies,
newspaper articles, short stories.
And they enjoy learning with this content.
And it's natural content.
It teaches you how to use the
language in the real world.
There again, I think two
important points that you made.
The greater the variety of input,
the more comfortable you're
going to be in the language.
But, uh, you know, more than anything
else, relax and enjoy the process.
So I will leave a link to your YouTube
channel in the description box.
Tell us again where people can find you.
Well, if you're learning English as
a second language, then you can find
me on YouTube at jforestenglish.
Well, I encourage people to go look
for you and to enjoy the process.
Thank you very much, Jennifer.
I enjoyed this discussion very much.
Thank you so much, Steve.
It's been a pleasure.